what happened is these girls are in the
London hate group and a lot of times
what's crazy too is they're not mad
about the show until they see the
comments and then they see the comments
and then they want the stream to get
anyways anyways so you know and I'm sure
there's ones that maybe have real
reasons to not like
um nothing crazy like I've never done
anything mad but you know I can be rude
at times I do four shows a week I'm sure
I'm not always the most patient I'm sure
like at times I haven't been as pleasant
as I could be but it's just guys when
you meet 20 to 50 people a week you just
it is really hard to treat everyone like
they're special